Gregory a perfect start to this year's
campaign for you just a Flawless game it
felt like how do you feel from your
perspective
um maybe it was Flawless so obviously
during the game I didn't know that but
um
felt great to play the tournament felt
great to play the first round I was very
nervous uh but you still get nervous
always nervous yeah always nervous um uh
Patrick had a long break from chess
but I
didn't feel like it would make a huge
difference so I was prepared for a very
complex fight
and
I played the variation against neither
would F3 Bishop E3 I played for the
first time in my life so obviously that
also was very nervous because there is
so much Theory
um was that part of your strategy the
fact that he hasn't played in a long
time perhaps he doesn't know all the
intricacies of this no no
be careful very important very seriously
so no no I expected him to know the
theory yes and and he did but I played
the variation with kingside Castle which
is uh not the main line
uh many many years ago we analyzed this
position with Judith polberg okay
this idea in general like we were
talking about like if they play H5 why
can White Castle kingside and H5 would
be just a weakness so it was more like
on the conceptual level we didn't
analyze too deep I didn't have any notes
on it but this idea that this variation
is playable stayed in my mind and I
decided wait for him to play H5 and then
short Castle because that's a very nice
idea correct and it felt like he also
understood that once you place the
Knight on A5 your attack comes just like
much easier right and this was a
critical moment I believe after Castle
he played Rook to C8 perhaps B6 was the
only right that's the move I expected
that's the movie you were expecting
right right and and I actually
even regret a little bit I was thinking
maybe instead of Castle I should play
Knight F5 right away I wasn't sure yes
uh maybe that would be good okay I see
computer says all zeros right so so
typical the typical yes right and after
Castle B6 still all zeros but it remains
are very comfortable right it's a game
it's a game yeah and after that it just
felt like
you are in the driver's seat you had an
easier plan as well and you're putting a
lot of pressure on your opponent when
you feel like
you're taking over completely
uh
probably after C5 after the move C5
right right after C5 I I felt like uh
yeah I should be okay but still I had to
kind of uh revisit my calculation
because uh originally when I played C5
um uh I didn't take Rook Jake C5
seriously so so when we went at one
point uh here yes right so so when he
played when he took on C5 I thought this
is just winning yes and then uh when uh
then I realized okay he can shake with a
rook and I had to
um uh calculate again and I found Knight
B3 and then yeah and this was this was I
mean Bishop C3 and after Bishop C3 I
thought I have a choice uh if if he
would play Bishop C3 I thought I thought
I'd have a choice between Queen C1 and
queen F2 and I felt like both probably
are good I think I I would play probably
queen of two but and that's the best
movie in the position yes yeah and if he
takes you probably think I just check I
just check and uh yeah and and uh look
the C8 and now you defend the pawn right
or oh no I was thinking Knight C5 Knight
C5 D7 uh that's even easier yeah yeah
yeah I mean and I will have uh Pawn for
two piece for two pawns uh sorry piece
for two pawns but you also have an
attack correct but with Queens on the
board I should be able to create an
attack on a king So Gregory
congratulations a great start for you go
get some rest we'll see you tomorrow
thank you Gregory a quick question for
you uh first of all good to see you uh
great to see you I mean it's a reunion
with uh the seniors uh quick question
this one comes from Twitter and we
thought we'd put you to work I mean
after all and the question from the
Twitter was
Gregory what is the difference between
junior chess and Senior chats
uh
um I mean it's obviously very different
right so uh in general uh the answer is
obvious uh in junior chat you will see
much more uh decisions based on
calculation and in senior chess uh you
would see many more decisions based on
field
right uh but uh as a senior I know that
if I want to stay in this game and
compete with Juniors I need to keep my
calculation sharp
I thought the answer had to do with good
looks but
I think you you presented very
good very very much good luck in your uh
in your tournament yeah congratulations
on your first round thank you very much
very nice